Hello beautiful nerds, I have a big announcement. After 10 years of being an independent production, with our 10th year probably being our biggest ever, putting out three special projects, Benoves and a best-selling book, I've decided to sell the show to Sirius XM, specifically to Stitcher, which is their podcast company. The same 99PI crew are going to make the show, I'm still going to host it, where our own editorial unit, it still be available anywhere to everyone. If you're subscribed now, you will stay subscribed. It's the same show. Someone else just collects the ad money and guides the business stuff. You'll never notice the sound of anything different, except I get to be involved more.
各位美丽的极客们，我有一个重大宣布。在作为独立制作团队走过10年，且第10年可能是我们有史以来最辉煌的一年——推出了三个特别项目、Benoves以及一本畅销书之后，我决定将节目出售给Sirius XM，具体来说是卖给他们的播客公司Stitcher。原班99PI人马将继续制作节目，我仍将担任主持人，我们拥有自己的编辑部门，节目依然会在任何地方向所有人开放。如果你现在已经订阅，你将继续保持订阅。节目还是原来的节目。只是换了人来收取广告费和管理商业事务。除了我能更多地参与其中外，你永远不会察觉到任何声音上的不同。
So much of my job has become running a business and not making a podcast. I desperately needed that to change. I chose Stitcher as my new partner because I already knew, trusted, and respected everyone there. The ball got rolling when I called Colin Anderson. He's the VP of Comedy at Irwolf, they're a part of Stitcher. I literally signed his paperwork a decade ago
我的工作中有太多时间花在经营业务上，而不是制作播客。我迫切需要改变这一点。我选择Stitcher作为我的新合作伙伴，因为我已经认识、信任并尊重那里的每一个人。这一切始于我给Colin Anderson打的一个电话。他是Irwolf的喜剧副总裁，他们是Stitcher的一部分。十年前，我甚至亲自签署了他的文书，
for him to work in this country. He was unfurlough from the Comedy Production Group at BBC Radio, and I signed the paperwork for him to work at KLW in San Francisco. And then he hooked me up with Natalie Moellum, the VP of business development and she and I hit it off right away because she also happens to be the sister of John Moellum who wrote and performed the amazing song story collaborations, Wild Ones and Jeanne Chance which are like our best episodes ever. So talking to her was like talking to a cousin. And the person who will be my boss is Peter Clowney.
让他能在这个国家工作。他当时从BBC广播的喜剧制作组借调出来，我签署了让他去旧金山KLW工作的文书。后来他把我介绍给了业务发展副总裁Natalie Moellum，我和她一见如故，因为她恰好是John Moellum的妹妹，John曾创作并表演了精彩的歌曲故事合作项目《Wild Ones》和《Jeanne Chance》，那简直是我们有史以来最好的几期节目。所以和她交谈就像和表亲聊天一样。而我未来的老板是Peter Clowney。
He's the head of original content in Stitcher. And he was my editor 15 years ago. We worked on pilots for public radio. And it's safe to say that if Peter hadn't been my editor then, 99% of visible wouldn't exist today. Then I met a bunch of the serious folks, and a lot of them had never heard of the show before, but by the end of our negotiations, they had heartfelt and insightful comments
他是Stitcher原创内容主管。15年前他曾是我的编辑。我们曾一起为公共广播制作试播集。可以肯定地说，如果当时没有Peter担任我的编辑，今天99%的可见度（99% Invisible）可能就不会存在。后来我见了一些Sirius的同事，他们中很多人以前从未听说过这个节目，但在谈判结束时，他们对
about episodes deep in the back catalog that I barely remembered. I like these folks, and you would like them too, but you'll never notice them. They just give me comfort. So what's going to happen with radiotopia? I am so proud of the things that PRX CEO Kerry Hoffman, executive producer Julie Shapiro, network director Audrey Mardovitch, and fundraiser Gina James and all the rest of the behind the scenes crew built with radiotopia. It became more successful than I ever imagined when we dreamed up in a cabin in rural Massachusetts several years ago. I raised money and worked
我们过往目录深处的剧集发表了发自肺腑且富有洞察力的评论。我喜欢这些人，你们也会喜欢他们的，但你们永远不会注意到他们的存在。他们只是让我感到安心。那么Radiotopia会怎样呢？我为PRX首席执行官Kerry Hoffman、执行制片人Julie Shapiro、网络总监Audrey Mardovitch、筹款人Gina James以及所有其他幕后工作人员与Radiotopia共同建立的一切感到无比自豪。几年前我们在马萨诸塞州乡村的一个小屋里构想它时，它的成功超出了我的想象。我筹集资金并与
side by side with amazing podcasters, each of them retaining ownership and control over their own work. Reutopia is a groundbreaking network and nonprofit collective. It has never been a company on purpose, and as such, even though I was the co-founder, I never owned any part of it. I think that was so weird to people that no one really understood it. I still believe in the ongoing mission of radio-topia and the amazing work of PRX and the forefront of public radio, and I hope you continue to support them. I certainly do. I'm personally donating a million dollars to PRX and radio-topia, so they keep going strong. Whatever cliche you have in mind about what happens in an acquisition
了不起的播客制作者们并肩工作，他们每个人都保留了对自己作品的所有权和控制权。Radiotopia是一个开创性的网络和非营利性集体。它从一开始就不是为了成为一家公司而存在的，因此，尽管我是联合创始人，但我从未拥有过它的任何股份。我觉得这对人们来说太奇怪了，以至于没人真正理解它。我仍然坚信Radiotopia的持续使命以及PRX在公共广播前沿所做的出色工作，我希望你们继续支持他们。我当然会。我个人向PRX和Radiotopia捐赠了一百万美元，以确保他们继续稳步前行。无论你对收购中发生的事情有什么陈词滥调，
when shows move to other networks. This isn't like that. A bunch of people from the PRX and serious teams work together with good intentions to transform a show that needed to evolve for the sake of its creator, and I am grateful for that. And I'm grateful to you for listening. And I am present as well, we'll keep on and grow, and the team will have even more opportunities to make more stuff and spin-offs with the full support of Stitcher and Sirius XM. I'm really excited to collaborate in ways I never imagined.
当节目转移到其他网络时，情况并非如此。PRX和Sirius团队的一群人怀着良好的初衷共同努力，为了创作者的利益去改造一个需要进化的节目，对此我心存感激。我也感谢你们的收听。我也会继续留任，我们会继续前进并成长，团队将在Stitcher和Sirius XM的全力支持下，获得更多制作内容和衍生节目的机会。我非常期待以我从未想象过的方式进行合作。
So thank you, beautiful nerds, for getting us here. And thanks for listening. We were all extremely busy the past couple of weeks, so right now I'm going to play for you a repeat, which is hosted by Delaney Hall, but nothing should be read into that. I'm still the host. This one just happens to be one of my favorite episodes, probably because it was hosted by Delaney Hall. Here you go.
所以，感谢你们，美丽的极客们，让我们走到今天。也感谢你们的收听。过去几周我们大家都非常忙碌，所以现在我要为你们播放一期重播，由Delaney Hall主持，但这并不意味着什么。我仍然是主持人。这期节目恰好是我最喜欢的剧集之一，大概是因为它是由Delaney Hall主持的。给你。
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Delaney Hall, filling in for Roman Mars. In 1997, a curator named Catherine Ott was learning her way around the Smithsonian National Museum of American History. She was new to the job, she specialized in medical science, and there was this one storage room in the building where she worked. It's like that classic what you'd think of as a dark, dusty, sort of scary, mildly mysterious storage room in a museum. There were drug jars,
这里是99% Invisible。我是Delaney Hall，代班Roman Mars。1997年，一位名叫Catherine Ott的策展人正在熟悉史密森尼国家美国历史博物馆的工作环境。她刚入职，专攻医学科学，她工作的大楼里有一个储藏室。就像你想象中博物馆里那种黑暗、尘土飞扬、有点吓人、略带神秘感的储藏室。里面有药罐，
there was parts of mannequin bodies laying around. But the weirdest thing was. There was this wheelchair that had go-cart wheels. It was completely customized. It had a recarrow seat that was used in Porsche cars, but I kept tripping over it and finally I'm like what the heck is this thing? So Catherine Ott started asking around. Where did this wheelchair come from? Why is it in storage? And no one at the castle, which is what the staff calls the main Smithsonian building, could really tell her. Nobody completely understood who had owned it.
还有散落的人体模型部件。但最奇怪的是，有一辆装有卡丁车轮子的轮椅。它经过了彻底的改装。它有一个保时捷汽车上使用的Recaro座椅，但我总是被它绊倒，最后我想，这到底是什么东西？于是Catherine Ott开始四处打听。这辆轮椅是从哪来的？为什么它在储藏室里？而在“城堡”（员工对史密森尼主楼的称呼）里，没有人能真正告诉她。没人完全清楚它是谁的。
It had been left at the door of the castle with a note pinned to it like an orphan in a basket. The note said this was a chair that belonged to Ed Roberts. We think it should be at the Smithsonian. Ed Roberts. I didn't recognize the name. Not yet. If you live in an American city and you don't personally use a wheelchair, you probably don't pay much attention to the small slope at most intersections between the sidewalk
它被遗弃在城堡的门口，上面别着一张纸条，就像篮子里的孤儿一样。纸条上写着：这是一把属于Ed Roberts的椅子。我们认为它应该放在史密森尼博物馆。Ed Roberts。我还没听过这个名字。如果你住在美国城市，且你自己不使用轮椅，你可能不会太注意大多数路口人行道与
and the street. It's just a ramp, a cut in the curb. They're all over the country now. Just about any place you find sidewalks. That's reporter Cynthia Gourney. But 60 years ago when Ed Roberts, the owner of that wheelchair, was young, the sidewalks at most urban intersections ended with a sharp drop-off. That's enough to stop a person in a wheelchair from reaching the next block without help. And the story of how the first widespread urban curb cuts came to be?
街道之间的小斜坡。那只是一个坡道，路缘石上的一个切口。现在全国到处都是。几乎任何有人行道的地方都有。那是记者Cynthia Gourney。但60年前，当那辆轮椅的主人Ed Roberts还年轻时，大多数城市路口的人行道尽头都是陡峭的落差。这足以阻止一个坐轮椅的人在没有帮助的情况下到达下一个街区。而关于第一次广泛的城市路缘坡道是如何出现的？
It starts with a movement that demanded society see disabled people in a new way. Ed Roberts was central to that movement and so were the hundreds of people who helped drag his wheelchair up Constitution Avenue right in the middle of Washington DC so it could end up at the Smithsonian. They insisted it was a piece of American history. Ed Roberts grew up in Berlin game near San Francisco. He was the oldest of four boys and he loved to play baseball but one day when he was 14 years old he got
这始于一场要求社会以新眼光看待残疾人的运动。Ed Roberts是那场运动的核心，数百名帮助将他的轮椅拖过华盛顿特区宪法大道的人也是如此，这样它最终才能进入史密森尼博物馆。他们坚持认为这是美国历史的一部分。Ed Roberts在旧金山附近的伯林格姆长大。他是四个男孩中的老大，他热爱打棒球，但有一天，当他14岁时，他
really sick with a fever. Within a few days, he was in the hospital. That's Zona Roberts, Ed's mom. She's 98 now. And within two days of that, he was in rush to an iron lung because he couldn't breathe any more on his own. It had polio. It had damaged his respiratory muscles so much that he needed the iron lung to stay alive.
发了高烧，病得很重。几天之内，他就进了医院。那是Ed的母亲Zona Roberts。她现在98岁了。在那之后的两天内，他被紧急送进了铁肺，因为他无法再自主呼吸了。他患上了小儿麻痹症。它严重损害了他的呼吸肌，以至于他需要铁肺才能活下去。
Iron lungs aren't made anymore, but back in the day, they were these full-body respirators that encased polio survivors in metal up to the neck and pulled air in and out of their lungs. Ed's polio wrecked a lot more than his breathing. It left him paralyzed below the neck. He could move two fingers on his left hand and that was it. His paralysis was permanent. The doctor who told Ed's parents their son had survived his high fever did not present this as good news. He said, well, how would you feel if you had to live in an iron lung the rest of your life? I don't imagine you've ever been in one. I've been in one and it's not a very good way to live. In order to escape the iron lung once in a while, Ed taught himself on his own a technique called frog breathing. That's a deep sea divers trick where you gulp oxygen into your lungs the way a
铁肺现在已经不再生产了，但在过去，它们是那种全身呼吸机，将小儿麻痹症幸存者包裹在金属中，直到颈部，并将空气吸入和排出他们的肺部。Ed的小儿麻痹症造成的破坏远不止呼吸。它使他颈部以下瘫痪。他只能移动左手的两根手指，仅此而已。他的瘫痪是永久性的。那位告诉Ed的父母他们的儿子在高烧中幸存下来的医生并没有把这当作好消息。他说，好吧，如果你余生都必须生活在铁肺里，你会感觉如何？我不认为你曾经住过铁肺。我住过，那不是一种很好的生活方式。为了偶尔逃离铁肺，Ed自学了一种叫做“青蛙呼吸法”的技术。那是深海潜水员的一种技巧，像
frog does. For polio survivors whose weakened breathing muscles weren't strong enough to inhale that needed oxygen, frog breathing met a person could get out of the iron lung for short stretches of time. You swallow air like that, you swallow it, and then you can breathe, and they kept telling them to stop it. That was not good for his body, and of course he kept doing it because it kept him alive. And Ed was determined to stay alive on his own terms. Here he is in a 60 minutes interview from 1989. There are very few people, even with the most severe disabilities who can't take control
青蛙一样将氧气吞入肺部。对于那些虚弱的呼吸肌不足以吸入所需氧气的小儿麻痹症幸存者来说，青蛙呼吸法意味着一个人可以短时间离开铁肺。你像那样吞咽空气，你吞下它，然后你就可以呼吸了，他们一直告诉他停止这样做。这对他的身体不好，当然他还是坚持这样做，因为它让他活了下来。Ed决心按照自己的方式活下去。这是他在1989年接受《60分钟》采访时的片段。即使是残疾最严重的人，也很少有人不能掌控
of their own life. The problem is that people around us don't expect this to. Think about your own life. If you have people taking care of you, making all your decisions, what is in life? Do it. Ed was tenacious, but everything was hard. He needed the iron lung while he was asleep,
自己的生活。问题是周围的人并不期望我们这样做。想想你自己的生活。如果有人照顾你，替你做所有的决定，那还叫生活吗？去做吧。Ed很顽强，但一切都很艰难。他睡觉时需要铁肺，
but the frog breathing let him leave it for a while during the day. So he stayed in school, going to campus once a week. When Ed did leave the house, his family ran the maneuvers. They were helping him navigate a world that wasn't built for a person in a wheelchair. Ed's brothers or his dad would help lift him into his chair, drag the chair out of the house, and then lift the chair over curbs and up and down stairs. Or if Zona were alone, she would wrangle strangers. I'd have to get somebody help me get the chair up the stairs. So it would be somebody in the back and somebody on the frame and get it up.
但青蛙呼吸法让他白天可以离开它一会儿。所以他坚持上学，每周去一次校园。当Ed离开家时，他的家人负责操作。他们帮助他在一个不是为轮椅使用者建造的世界中穿行。Ed的兄弟或父亲会帮忙把他抬进椅子，把椅子拖出房子，然后把椅子抬过路缘石，上下楼梯。或者如果Zona独自一人，她会找陌生人帮忙。我得找人帮我把椅子抬上楼梯。所以会有一个人在后面，一个人在框架上，把它抬上去。
Or sometimes it would just be me. Ed graduated from high school then from a local community college. But when he wanted to go on to Berkeley in 1962, the university at first said no. He was just too disabled. And where could he safely live? The iron lung, which he still used every night, wouldn't fit in a dorm room. Until finally, somebody suggested housing him at the campus hospital. A patient's room remade into a living space for Ed and all his equipment.
或者有时就只有我一个人。Ed高中毕业，然后从当地的一所社区学院毕业。但当他想在1962年进入伯克利大学时，学校起初拒绝了。他残疾太严重了。而且他能安全地住在哪里？他每晚仍需使用的铁肺放不进宿舍房间。直到最后，有人建议让他住在校园医院。一个病房被改造成了Ed和他所有设备的居住空间。
This is Ed Roberts, five, two, take one, September 15. his equipment. In a series of oral history interviews, much later, Ed remembered what it was like to start as a Berkeley undergrad. What it was like. There's a combination of excitement and scary. An attendant would wheel at D.H. class, and then Ed would recruit a classmate to help him take notes. And I did a certain liquor announcement that he could get a class and usually
这是Ed Roberts，五，二，第一条，9月15日。他的设备。在很久之后的一系列口述历史采访中，Ed回忆起作为伯克利本科生开始生活是什么感觉。是什么感觉。这是一种兴奋和恐惧的结合。护理员会推着他去上课，然后Ed会招募一名同学帮他记笔记。我会做一个特定的公告，他可以去上课，通常
find a good looking guy at Woolbert. He'd give the woman a piece of carbon paper. She would take notes during the lecture, and then she'd give the carbon copy back to Ed at the end. It's such a way to take notes during the lecture and then she'd give the carbon copy back to Ed at the end. Ed did so much studying and reading that the mouth wand he used to turn the pages of books started pushing his teeth out of shape. So campus officials saw this experiment was working.
在Woolbert找一个好看的家伙。他会给那个女生一张复写纸。她在讲座期间做笔记，然后在最后把复写件还给Ed。这是一种在讲座期间做笔记的方式，然后在最后把复写件还给Ed。Ed做了大量的学习和阅读，以至于他用来翻书的嘴部棒开始把他的牙齿顶得变形了。所以校园官员看到这个实验奏效了。
Newspapers wrote stories about Ed. His mom still likes to make fun of the headlines. Help us, cripple, ghost of college, that's one we all love. And then a second quadriplegic student moved into Ed's makeshift hospital dorm. A young man who had been paralyzed in a diving accident and was initially told he should just get used to life
报纸写了关于Ed的故事。他妈妈仍然喜欢拿标题开玩笑。救救我们，残废，大学的幽灵，这是我们都喜欢的标题。然后第二个四肢瘫痪的学生搬进了Ed的临时医院宿舍。一个在跳水事故中瘫痪的年轻人，起初被告知他应该习惯
as a shut-in. Then a few more arrived, both to live in the hospital and to find lodgings off campus. The word started to spread. Something unusual was going on at Berkeley. These students had profound and visible disabilities. The state paid special attendance to heft their wheelchairs, up staircases, and visible disabilities. The state paid special attendance to heft their wheelchairs, up staircases,
闭门不出的生活。然后又来了几个，有的住在医院，有的在校外找住处。消息开始传开了。伯克利发生了一些不寻常的事情。这些学生有严重且明显的残疾。州政府支付特殊的护理费用来抬他们的轮椅，上楼梯，明显的残疾。州政府支付特殊的护理费用来抬他们的轮椅，上楼梯，
and intellectual halls. You couldn't miss the new presence on campus. And don't forget, this was the 1960s. Ed went to Berkeley at the same year that James Meredith, a black man, went to University of Mississippi and integrated it. That's a story in Steve Brown. He has a genetic syndrome
和教学楼。你无法忽视校园里的这种新存在。别忘了，这是20世纪60年代。Ed进入伯克利的那一年，黑人James Meredith进入密西西比大学并实现了种族融合。那是Steve Brown的故事。他患有一种遗传综合征，
that among other things makes his bones break easily, so he's a sometimes wheelchair user and a co-founder of the Institute on Disability Culture. So the 60s were a time of lots of protests and lots of reform and lots of change and you know there's this very technical historical term it was in the air and it was in the air. And it was in the air. It was in the air for disabled people too. That improvised dorm in the campus hospital. Those rooms turned into the headquarters for an exuberant and irreverent group of organizers like Ed and Hale Zuckas, an assertive guy with cerebral palsy
除其他外，这使他的骨头容易折断，所以他有时使用轮椅，也是残疾文化研究所的联合创始人。所以60年代是一个充满抗议、改革和变革的时代，你知道有一个非常专业的历史术语，它在空气中，它在空气中。它在空气中。对于残疾人来说，它也在空气中。校园医院里的那个临时宿舍。那些房间变成了像Ed和Hale Zuckas这样充满活力和叛逆的组织者的总部，Hale是一个患有脑瘫的自信家伙，
who communicated with a word board and a pointer strapped to his head. They called themselves the rolling quads. And like a few other coalitions of disabled young people around the country, they started using a new kind of language to talk about their needs and rights. The radical idea that people with disabilities had civil rights, the right to education, to jobs, to respect, to real inclusion in public life, this fit right into the revolutionary spirit of the 1960s and early 70s.
他用单词板和绑在头上的指针进行交流。他们称自己为“滚动四肢残疾者”（Rolling Quads）。像全国其他几个残疾年轻人联盟一样，他们开始使用一种新的语言来谈论他们的需求和权利。残疾人拥有公民权利、受教育权、就业权、尊重权、真正融入公共生活的权利这一激进思想，完全契合了60年代和70年代初的革命精神。
And the Berkeley Disabled students had a Berkeley reputation. At that time, it was an explosive place. That's Judy Human, who had polio as a kid back in the 1940s and has used a wheelchair since then. She was a young New York disability rights agitator when she moved to Berkeley for graduate school. It was our responsibility to break down the doors and we had a lot of fun because it was much easier to organize a demonstration in Berkeley, then in Manhattan. You know, so we could get 30 to 50 wheelchair riders to come to City Hall. That's a pretty large number. Notice she said wheelchair riders with a D like bicycle riders. It doesn't really have
伯克利的残疾学生在伯克利很有名。那时，那是一个爆炸性的地方。那是Judy Heumann，她小时候在40年代患过小儿麻痹症，从那时起就一直使用轮椅。当她搬到伯克利读研究生时，她是一位年轻的纽约残疾人权利煽动者。打破大门是我们的责任，我们玩得很开心，因为在伯克利组织示威比在曼哈顿容易得多。你知道，我们可以召集30到50名轮椅骑手去市政厅。那是一个相当大的数字。注意她说的是“轮椅骑手”（wheelchair riders），带个D，就像自行车骑手一样。它真的没有
the same feel as wheelchair bound, right? And disable people from other parts of the country were coming to Berkeley. To go to school, to look for work, to be a part of a disability vibrant community. I was instantly attracted to them and what they were doing. Debbie Kaplan broke her neck in a diving accident just after college. When she decided to study law, Berkeley admitted her, and Ed and the Rolling Quad said, right away, come work with us. I mean, to people in the disability community, we hung on to each other because we all had this idea about who we were, and nobody else around us did.
那种“轮椅束缚”（wheelchair bound）的感觉，对吧？来自全国各地的残疾人来到伯克利。去上学，找工作，成为一个充满活力的残疾人社区的一部分。我立刻被他们和他们所做的事情吸引了。Debbie Kaplan在大学毕业后的一次跳水事故中摔断了脖子。当她决定学习法律时，伯克利录取了她，Ed和Rolling Quads立刻说，来和我们一起工作。我的意思是，对于残疾人社区的人来说，我们紧紧依靠在一起，因为我们都有关于我们是谁的想法，而周围其他人都没有。
You know, I mean, everybody else was stuck in the standard way of thinking about disability back then. What? Charity and public welfare and disability means you can't do anything. Meaning, you know, Jerry Lewis-Telethon. [♪ Music playing in background, you know that we're gonna do a show for you now? 20 hours? Coast to coast? You know that?
你知道，我的意思是，当时其他所有人都陷入了关于残疾的标准思维方式。什么？慈善和公共福利，残疾意味着你什么都做不了。意思是，你知道，Jerry Lewis慈善马拉松。 [♪ 背景音乐播放，你知道我们要为你表演节目了吗？20个小时？从海岸到海岸？你知道吗？
Mm-hmm. Okay, now let's see if we can get the people out there to love you too. Okay. All right. The Jerry Lewis-Telethon was the late comedian's annual marathon fundraiser for muscular dystrophy. He mugged for the camera and brought in celebrity singers and spent a lot of time smiling down at cute, well-dressed children in wheelchairs.
嗯。好的，现在让我们看看能不能让外面的人也爱你。好的。好的。Jerry Lewis慈善马拉松是这位已故喜剧演员为肌肉萎缩症举办的年度马拉松筹款活动。他在镜头前做鬼脸，请来名人歌手，花了很多时间微笑着看着轮椅上可爱、穿着考究的孩子们。
The rising generation of disability rights activists hated it. Well, we just would cringe every Memorial Day weekend knowing that all these people were watching Jerry Lewis squeezing money out of people by dramatically playing up the most horrid stereotypes about disability that having a disability is a fate worse than death, that we should be pitted, that if we do anything we are brave and yet really not real people. I knew that the only other time I saw disabled people on TV, we're doing those telephones. This is Laurence Carter Long. He's communications director for the Disability Rights and Education Defense Fund. When Laurence was five, he was a literal poster child for the United Fund charity because he
新一代残疾人权利活动家讨厌它。嗯，我们每到阵亡将士纪念日周末就会感到畏缩，因为知道所有这些人都在看Jerry Lewis通过戏剧性地放大关于残疾的最可怕的刻板印象来从人们那里榨取金钱，即残疾是一种比死亡更糟糕的命运，我们应该被怜悯，如果我们做任何事情我们就是勇敢的，但实际上并不是真正的人。我知道我唯一一次在电视上看到残疾人，就是在做那些电话筹款。这是Laurence Carter Long。他是残疾人权利与教育辩护基金的通讯主任。Laurence五岁时，他是联合基金慈善机构的字面意义上的海报儿童，因为他
was born with cerebral palsy and he was cute. I was on the side of buses. I was in fun raising appeals and everybody would go, ah, I think, open up the checkbooks. It wasn't until I got a little bit older when I was in college and I thought, wait a minute, what's the subtext of that? And the subtext was, well, you don't want to end up like this poor kid, do you? Then give us some money.
天生患有脑瘫，而且他很可爱。我在公共汽车的侧面。我在筹款呼吁中，每个人都会说，啊，我想，打开支票簿。直到我大一点，上大学时，我才想，等一下，那背后的潜台词是什么？潜台词是，好吧，你不想落得像这个可怜的孩子一样，对吧？那就给我们一些钱。
As an adult, Lawrence would go on to study the way disabled people were portrayed in the movies and on television and generally in the public consciousness. What became very clear is there were certain narratives that got told often, you know, that disability was something that we were to be afraid of, that disabled people were objects of pity. And I remember in 1972 there was a controversy around the Jerry Lewis telephone where Jerry Lewis said, the man upstairs goofed. I think the man upstairs goofed in made a mistake. And I think he put people like myself and all these lovely people with the celebrity phones
成年后，Lawrence继续研究残疾人在电影、电视以及公众意识中被描绘的方式。变得非常清楚的是，有些叙事经常被讲述，你知道，残疾是我们应该害怕的东西，残疾人是怜悯的对象。我记得1972年围绕Jerry Lewis电话筹款发生了一场争议，当时Jerry Lewis说，“楼上的那个人搞砸了。我想楼上的那个人搞砸了，犯了一个错误。我认为他把像我这样的人和所有这些可爱的名人电话筹款人放在这里
here to repair that goof. It rang that bell in my mind in terms of, is that what people think of me? That I'm one of God's mistakes? Back at Berkeley, the Rolling Quads and Ed Roberts in particular were one big antidote to the Jerry Lewis telephone. Ed flirted with women. He got arrested in college for peeing outside a bar.
是为了修复那个错误。”这在我的脑海中敲响了警钟，人们是这样看我的吗？我是上帝的错误之一？回到伯克利，Rolling Quads，特别是Ed Roberts，是Jerry Lewis电话筹款的一大解毒剂。Ed和女性调情。他在大学时因为在酒吧外小便而被捕。
He told dark jokes about quadriplegia. Like when a doctor told him he was going to be a vegetable. And Ed replied, fine, I'll be in artichoke. Tough and prickly on the outside with a tender heart. A testing counselor once pronounced Ed to be very aggressive. Ed liked recounting his response. Well, if you were paralyzed from the neck down,
他讲关于四肢瘫痪的黑色笑话。比如当医生告诉他他会变成一个植物人时。Ed回答说，好吧，我会成为一个洋蓟。外表坚硬多刺，内心柔软。一位测试顾问曾宣称Ed非常有攻击性。Ed喜欢复述他的回应。好吧，如果你颈部以下瘫痪了，
don't you think aggressiveness would be an asset? The nature, I think, of access of being included meant that you had to, in some ways, force yourself upon the world and say, we're here. Hey, hey, hey, because the tendency, the programming for the rest of the country, even here in Berkeley at first, was to say, we don't want to see that.
你不觉得攻击性会是一种资产吗？我认为，准入、被包容的本质意味着你必须在某种程度上强加于世界，并说，我们在这里。嘿，嘿，嘿，因为全国其他地方的倾向，甚至起初在伯克利，都是说，我们不想看到那个。
You're going to make those normal people uncomfortable. But by the time Ed Roberts was in graduate school at Berkeley, the disabled students were noticeably, unmistakably, part of the community. Even more so because some were zipping around in power chairs, which had been invented to help wounded veterans, and were starting to be more available to the general public. Ed got really interested in power chairs when he first watched another quadriplegic try one out. And now he had one of these new portable ventilators that attached to his wheelchair. So even though he still used the iron lung at night,
你会让那些正常人感到不舒服。但当Ed Roberts在伯克利读研究生时，残疾学生已经明显地、毫无疑问地成为了社区的一部分。更重要的是，因为有些人坐着电动轮椅四处穿梭，这种轮椅最初是为了帮助受伤的退伍军人而发明的，并开始向公众提供。Ed在第一次看到另一个四肢瘫痪者尝试电动轮椅时，就对它产生了浓厚的兴趣。现在他有了这种新的便携式呼吸机，可以连接到他的轮椅上。所以即使他晚上仍然使用铁肺，
he could stay away from it for a lot longer. And there was a girl. I fell in love. Like many people do. We do that as well. Had it became ridiculously inconvenient to have my attendant pushing me around in my wheelchair with my girlfriend. It was an extra person that I didn't need to be more intimate. With a power chair, a person like Ed would still need an attendant for some things. Not for locomotion though, not to go on a date. I learned how to drive a power wheelchair in one day. I was so motivated.
他可以离开它更长时间。而且有一个女孩。我坠入爱河了。像许多人一样。我们也这样做。让我的护理员推着我的轮椅和我的女朋友一起走变得非常不方便。这是一个我不需要的额外的人，为了更亲密。有了电动轮椅，像Ed这样的人仍然需要护理员来做某些事情。但不是为了移动，不是为了约会。我一天就学会了驾驶电动轮椅。我太有动力了。
It had changed in many ways my perception of my disability. To have myself, and she jumped on my lap, and we rode off into the sunset more to the closest more tail. But think about this. For more than a decade you've been able to get around because somebody is behind you pushing your chair. And now you're under your own power. You get to leave that wheelchair attendant behind. But you still have to contend with curbs.
它在许多方面改变了我对残疾的看法。我把自己弄上去，她跳到我的膝盖上，我们骑着车驶向夕阳，前往最近的汽车旅馆。但想想看。十多年来，你一直能够四处走动，因为有人在你身后推着你的椅子。现在你靠自己的力量了。你可以把那个轮椅护理员甩在身后。但你仍然必须应对路缘石。
If you're trying to get across the street and there are no curb cuts. Six inches might as well be Mount Everest. Six inches makes all the difference in the world. If you can't get over that curb. These guys could only roll independently once they could get over the curb drop-offs on the way. And yeah, they could go hunt for a driveway, but that's dangerous for somebody in a wheelchair. A driveway sends you right out into traffic. And yeah, they could go hunt for a driveway, but that's dangerous for somebody in a wheelchair.
如果你试图过马路，而没有路缘坡道。六英寸可能就像珠穆朗玛峰。六英寸带来了天壤之别。如果你不能越过那个路缘石。这些人只有在能够越过路上的路缘石落差后，才能独立滚动。是的，他们可以去寻找车道，但这对于坐轮椅的人来说很危险。车道会把你直接送入车流中。是的，他们可以去寻找车道，但这对于坐轮椅的人来说很危险。
A driveway sends you right out into traffic. The whole point of a marked intersection is that it shows you this is where it's safe to cross. The power chair riders, actually all the wheelchair riders, needed what we now call curb cuts. Those slopes at the corners that make it easy to roll between sidewalk and street. And here's where it would be great to be able to tell you about the inventor of the curb cut. The clever person who first thought of cutting little ramps,
车道会把你直接送入车流中。标记路口的全部意义在于它向你展示这是过马路安全的地方。电动轮椅骑手，实际上所有的轮椅骑手，都需要我们现在所说的路缘坡道。那些在角落的斜坡，使得在人行道和街道之间滚动变得容易。在这里，如果能告诉你路缘坡道的发明者是谁就好了。那个第一个想到切出小坡道的聪明人，
so people could roll into intersections instead of having to step off curves. But nobody knows who that was. All we know is that they were not a standard feature yet and most intersections, not in Berkeley, not anywhere. Back in the 1940s and 50s, there were a few communities across the country where people had tried to make parts of the built environment more accessible. For example, there was a coach in Illinois working with disabled soldiers who badgered reluctant officials at the University of Illinois. Like, shame on you, these men and women were injured
这样人们就可以滚动进入路口，而不必从路缘石上走下来。但没人知道那是谁。我们只知道它们还不是标准配置，大多数路口都没有，伯克利没有，任何地方都没有。早在40年代和50年代，全国有几个社区的人们试图让部分建筑环境更容易进入。例如，伊利诺伊州有一位教练与残疾士兵一起工作，他纠缠伊利诺伊大学不情愿的官员。就像，真丢人，这些男人和女人受伤了
fighting for us until finally the school set up a rehab and education program on its most important campus with wheelchair sports and wood ramps into buildings. But by the late 1960s and 70s, this new wave of young disabled activists like the Rolling Quads, they weren't gonna wait around for the occasional enlightened college coach. They demanded. They were insistent. They didn't wait for permission. You still hear these stories about the Rolling Quads going out on Commando raids at midnight,
为我们而战，直到最后学校在其最重要的校园里建立了一个康复和教育项目，有轮椅运动和进入建筑物的木坡道。但到了60年代末和70年代，像Rolling Quads这样新一代的年轻残疾活动家，他们不会等待偶尔开明的大学教练。他们要求。他们坚持不懈。他们没有等待许可。你仍然听到这些关于Rolling Quads在午夜进行突击行动的故事，
guys in wheelchairs with their attendants using sledgehammers or jackhammers to bust up curbs, build their own ramps, and force the city into action. But the story that there were midnight commandos was a little bit exaggerated, actually. Exaggerated, he said. That's Eric Dibner. In the early 1970s, he was a disabled student's attendant at Berkeley, sort of a rolling quad's fellow traveler. And yeah, he says, maybe a few of them got impatient, maybe they did go poor a few ramps themselves.
坐着轮椅的家伙和他们的护理员使用大锤或手提钻来砸碎路缘石，建造他们自己的坡道，并强迫城市采取行动。但关于有午夜突击队员的故事其实有点夸张。夸张，他说。那是Eric Dibner。70年代初，他是伯克利残疾学生的护理员，算是Rolling Quads的同路人。是的，他说，也许他们中的一些人变得不耐烦了，也许他们确实自己铺设了一些坡道。
We got a bag or two of concrete and mixed it up and took it to the corners that would most ease the route. So that occurred on, I'd say, less than half a dozen corners. Did any of these runs occur at midnight? Yes, they were all done in the under cloak of darkness. It may have been against the law, right? And so you can call them commando raids or whatever. Those commando raids never happened on a grand scale. Instead, most of the progress made by the rolling quads was a little more bureaucratic, a little more how real change often gets made. One day, in 1971, the rolling quads show up at the Berkeley City Council in a posse.
我们拿了一两袋混凝土，混合起来，带到最能缓解路线的角落。所以这种情况发生在，我想说，不到六个角落。这些行动中有任何是在午夜进行的吗？是的，它们都是在夜幕掩护下完成的。这可能违反了法律，对吧？所以你可以称它们为突击行动或任何东西。那些突击行动从未在大规模上发生过。相反，Rolling Quads取得的大部分进展更官僚一些，更像真正的变革通常是如何实现的。有一天，在1971年，Rolling Quads成群结队地出现在伯克利市议会。
Ed Roberts, who by now is a polypsych grad student, Hail Zuckis, the guy with a pointer and the wordboard who's learned Russian and is finishing a math degree, and all their friends disabled and not. When you picture this, remember that Berkeley's council chambers are not very big. So we really were kind of stunned to see a whole lot of people in wheelchairs wheeling into the council meeting
Ed Roberts，此时已经是心理学研究生，Hale Zuckas，那个带着指针和单词板、学会了俄语并即将完成数学学位的家伙，以及他们所有的残疾和非残疾朋友。当你想象这个画面时，记住伯克利的议会厅并不大。所以我们确实有点震惊地看到一大群坐着轮椅的人滚进议会会议，
and saying that they wanted to have curb cuts on every street corner in Berkeley because they needed to get around and they want to be able to get around by themselves. That's Lonnie Hancock, who was a Berkeley City Council member and then the city's mayor before joining the California state legislature.
并说他们想在伯克利的每个街角都有路缘坡道，因为他们需要四处走动，他们想能够自己四处走动。那是Lonnie Hancock，她曾是伯克利市议会议员，后来成为该市市长，之后加入了加州州议会。
We were on a stage, as I remember, so we were elevated and the people in wheelchairs were down below us, looking up at us and just looking into their faces and realizing the effort that it took for them to be there and that they were requesting something that had never been done to our knowledge anywhere on Earth. It was an overwhelming sensation, but realizing that it's something that we could do and should do and would do. And so they did the world's first widespreadUTS program. City Council Minutes, September 28, 1971. Hmm. Declaring it to be the policy of the city, that streets and sidewalks be designed and constructed
据我记得，我们在舞台上，所以我们被抬高了，而坐轮椅的人在我们下面，抬头看着我们，只是看着他们的脸，意识到他们来到这里所付出的努力，以及他们正在请求做一些据我们所知在地球上任何地方从未做过的事情。这是一种压倒性的感觉，但意识到这是我们可以做、应该做并且会做的事情。所以他们做了世界上第一个广泛的UTS项目。市议会会议记录，1971年9月28日。嗯。宣布这是城市的政策，街道和人行道的设计和建造
to facilitate circulation by handicap persons within major commercial areas. That curve cuts be made immediately at 15 specified corners throughout the city. The motion carried unanimously. By the mid-1970s, the Disability Rights Movement was growing and spreading. Groups with a rolling quad sort of attitude
应促进残疾人在主要商业区域内的流通。在全市15个指定角落立即修建路缘坡道。动议一致通过。到70年代中期，残疾人权利运动正在成长和蔓延。具有Rolling Quads那种态度的团体
were multiplying around the country and even world. And one adjective was pretty much key to the new movement over the next two decades. Independent. And for everybody in this crusade, the physical fixes list was ambitious, things that had to change in the built environment to make real independence possible. Not just curb cuts, wheelchair lifts on buses, ramps alongside staircases, elevators with reachable buttons in public buildings, and accessible bathrooms. Service counters, low enough to let a person in a wheelchair be attended to face-to-face, respectfully, not peer down at from way on high. So they got to work.
在全国甚至世界各地成倍增加。而一个形容词在接下来的二十年里对这场新运动来说几乎是关键的。独立。对于这场运动中的每个人来说，物理修复清单雄心勃勃，为了实现真正的独立，建筑环境中必须改变的事情。不仅仅是路缘坡道，公共汽车上的轮椅升降机，楼梯旁的坡道，公共建筑中带有可触及按钮的电梯，以及无障碍浴室。服务柜台，低到足以让坐轮椅的人面对面地得到服务，恭敬地，而不是从高处俯视。所以他们开始工作了。
They're tired, they're grubby, they're uncomfortable, but their spirits are soaring. The sin in its San Francisco's H.E.W. headquarters now is in its third day, and 125 disabled and handicapped are pledging to continue the sin through tomorrow night, if not longer. In 1977, disability rights protesters hit federal office buildings in 11 cities at once. They were pushing the government to act on long neglected rules protecting the disabled in all facilities taking federal money. The San Francisco protests turned into a month-long sit-in with steady news coverage of people in wheelchairs taking care of each other and refusing to leave. The Occupation Army and Wheel Chairs shows no signs of calling that off. The sit-in worked, and these images of the grown-up disability demonstrator uninterested in pity kept accumulating.
他们很累，很脏，很不舒服，但他们的精神在飞扬。旧金山H.E.W.总部现在的静坐已进入第三天，125名残疾人和残障人士承诺将静坐持续到明天晚上，甚至更久。1977年，残疾人权利抗议者同时冲击了11个城市的联邦办公大楼。他们敦促政府对长期被忽视的保护所有接受联邦资金设施中残疾人的规则采取行动。旧金山的抗议活动演变成了一场为期一个月的静坐，新闻持续报道着坐轮椅的人们互相照顾并拒绝离开。“轮椅占领军”没有表现出任何放弃的迹象。静坐奏效了，这些成年残疾示威者对怜悯不感兴趣的形象不断积累。
1980, disabled people in Denver stage a protest demanding curb cuts. They've already blocked traffic until city transit officials promised to put in wheelchair lifts on all the buses. Now a couple guys in their own wheelchairs lean over for the photographers to whack down at concrete curbs. They're holding sledgehammers. 1988. Trustees at Gallaudet to National University for the Deaf try to appoint a president who, like every other so far, is not deaf. Angry students boycott classes and shut down the campus
1980年，丹佛的残疾人在要求路缘坡道时举行了抗议。他们已经封锁了交通，直到城市交通官员承诺在所有公共汽车上安装轮椅升降机。现在，几个坐在自己轮椅上的家伙俯身让摄影师拍摄他们猛击混凝土路缘石。他们拿着大锤。1988年。加劳德特大学（国立聋人大学）的受托人试图任命一位像迄今为止其他所有人一样不是聋人的校长。愤怒的学生抵制课程并关闭了校园，
until their candidate becomes the college's first deaf president. And in 1990, when the sweeping Americans with Disabilities Act gets hung up in the House of Representatives, disabled demonstrators in front of the Capitol building leave their wheelchairs and crawl up the marble steps to make sure that that bill gets through. Wherever you turned on the television, that was the image that you saw that millions of Americans saw. We're disabled people crawling up the stairs of the United States Capitol, not asking, not begging,
直到他们的候选人成为该校第一位聋人校长。1990年，当全面的《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）在众议院陷入僵局时，国会大厦前的残疾示威者离开轮椅，爬上大理石台阶，以确保该法案获得通过。无论你打开电视，你看到的都是那个画面，数百万美国人看到的画面。我们是残疾人爬上美国国会大厦的台阶，不是请求，不是乞求，
demanding, demanding to be a part of society, boldly going where everyone else had gone before. The ADA wasn't the first federal legislation designed to remove barriers for disabled people, but its reach was unprecedented. It mandated access and accommodation for the disabled in all places open to the public, businesses, lodgings, transportation,
而是要求，要求成为社会的一部分，大胆地走向每个人以前去过的地方。《ADA》不是第一部旨在消除残疾人障碍的联邦立法，但其影响是前所未有的。它强制要求在所有对公众开放的地方、企业、住宿、交通、
employment. And it had qualifiers to be sure. The ADA required only what was quote unquote reasonable for employers and builders and so on. And there was a lot of argument about that word reasonable. But at the Bill's signing ceremony in 1990, President George H. W. Bush spoke with emotion about the recent fall of the Berlin Wall, which had divided communist East Germany from the West. Note the tool he mentions. And now I sign legislation, which takes a sledgehammer to another wall. One which has for too many generations separated Americans with disabilities from the freedom they could glimpse but not grass. And once again we rejoice as this barrier falls for claiming together we will not accept, we will not excuse, we will not
就业方面为残疾人提供准入和便利。当然，它也有限定条件。《ADA》只要求雇主和建筑商等提供所谓的“合理”要求。关于“合理”这个词有很多争论。但在1990年的法案签署仪式上，乔治·H·W·布什总统激动地谈到了最近柏林墙的倒塌，那堵墙将共产主义东德与西方隔开。注意他提到的工具。“现在我签署立法，它对另一堵墙挥动了大锤。这堵墙几十年来一直将美国残疾人与他们能瞥见却无法触及的自由隔开。我们再次欢呼，因为这道障碍倒塌了，宣称我们共同将不接受，我们将不原谅，我们将不
tolerate discrimination in America." Ed Roberts, the guy you see Berkeley officials once thought was too crippled for their university, finished his master's degree, taught on campus, and co-founded the Center for Independent Living, a disability service organization that became a model for hundreds of others around the world. He also married, fathered a son, divorced, won a MacArthur Genius Grant, and for nearly a decade ran the whole California State Department of Rehabilitation Services. He was 56, an international name and independence for the disabled, when a heart attack killed him.
容忍美国的歧视。”Ed Roberts，那个你看到的伯克利官员曾经认为对他们的大学来说太残废的家伙，完成了他的硕士学位，在校园任教，并共同创立了独立生活中心，这是一个残疾服务组织，成为了世界各地数百个其他组织的典范。他还结婚、生子、离婚、获得了麦克阿瑟天才奖，并管理了近十年的整个加州州立康复服务部。当心脏病发作夺走他的生命时，他56岁，是国际上残疾人独立运动的名字。
I was stunned. Julia Sainn runs disability rights and resources in Charlotte, North Carolina. It's one of those programs based on the Center for Independent Living Model. And in 1995, Julia was at the annual March and meeting of the National Council for Independent Living in Washington, DCio was at the annual March and meeting of the National Council for Independent Living in Washington, D.C. Ed had died a few weeks earlier, and a special memorial for him was now on the schedule. We were going to be marching down the main streets to the Capitol. They were going to put Ed's wheelchair be at the front of the march.
我惊呆了。Julia Sain在北卡罗来纳州夏洛特市经营残疾人权利与资源中心。它是基于独立生活中心模式的项目之一。1995年，Julia在华盛顿特区举行的全国独立生活委员会年度游行和会议上。Ed在几周前去世了，现在日程上安排了一个为他举行的特别纪念活动。我们将沿着主街游行到国会大厦。他们打算把Ed的轮椅放在游行队伍的最前面。
The marchers followed the empty wheelchair, which was being dragged along by Ed's attendant until they reached the Senate office building. And then once inside, speakers got up to honor Ed's life and legacy. And Senator Tom Harkin from Iowa gave the eulogy. And he said, you know, when Martin Luther King Jr. passed, they built statues to him in honor of him. But Ed Roberts, Harkin, said, there was a better way to honor this warrior for another kind of civil rights. They're going to tear down barriers in his name. And every curb cut is a memorial to Ed Roberts.
游行队伍跟随着那辆空轮椅，由埃德的护理员拖着，直到他们到达参议院办公大楼。进入大楼后，演讲者们纷纷起身，缅怀埃德的一生及其留下的遗产。来自爱荷华州的参议员汤姆·哈金致了悼词。他说，你知道，当马丁·路德·金去世时，人们为他建造雕像以示纪念。但哈金说，对于这位为另一种民权而战的战士，纪念他有更好的方式。他们要以他的名义拆除障碍。每一个路缘坡道都是对埃德·罗伯茨的纪念。
memorial to Ed Roberts. And sometime later after the marchers had gone home or back to their hotels, Ed Roberts attendant pushed the wheelchair the rest of the way and left it on the front steps of this Smithsonian. The chair is beautiful to me. That's Catherine Ott, the curator at the Smithsonian National Museum of American History. She's the one who found Ed's wheelchair in the storage room. His chair now remains on permanent display on the Smithsonian's website. It's all banged and dinged and the imprint of him. There's a big battery cage in the back. It's all customized.
对埃德·罗伯茨的纪念。后来，当游行者们回家或回到酒店后，埃德·罗伯茨的护理员把轮椅推到了最后一段路，并把它留在了史密森尼博物馆的前台阶上。对我来说，这把椅子很美。那是史密森尼美国国家历史博物馆的策展人凯瑟琳·奥特。是她在储藏室里发现了埃德的轮椅。他的椅子现在在史密森尼的网站上永久展出。它伤痕累累，凹凸不平，留下了他的印记。后面有一个很大的电池笼。它是完全定制的。
He has a bumper sticker with a statue of liberty on it, with the big letters, yes, exclamation point. But having Ed's wheelchair at the Smithsonian does not mean everything is now okay, as anybody in the disability community will tell you. Every broken bus wheelchair lift, every temporarily out of function subway elevator, every Uber driver who won't take a wheelchair, every open manhole cover or car blocking the sidewalk. Most of the New York City subway system, which city leaders years ago decided was just too complicated to make fully accessible, the built environment is still littered with barriers.
他有一个保险杠贴纸，上面印着自由女神像，还有大大的“YES”字样，后面跟着感叹号。但是，在史密森尼博物馆展出埃德的轮椅并不意味着现在一切都好了，正如残障人士社区的任何人都会告诉你的那样。每一个坏掉的公交车轮椅升降机，每一个暂时无法使用的地铁电梯，每一个拒绝搭载轮椅的优步司机，每一个敞开的井盖或挡住人行道的汽车。纽约市的大部分地铁系统——城市领导者多年前认为要实现完全无障碍化太复杂了——这个建筑环境仍然充斥着障碍。
Curb cuts are common now, but they're not at every intersection, even in Berkeley. And when it comes to attitudes and prejudice and assumptions about what people with disabilities can do and achieve and enjoy. We've not yet accomplished full inclusion. We have managed to make it easier by and large for people to get into the building. But have we done the work that's going to make it easier for them to get the education? For again, to not only have a job, but have a career, those things don't yet exist for many people. Even in Berkeley.
路缘坡道现在很常见，但并非每个路口都有，即使在伯克利也是如此。当谈到对残障人士能做什么、能实现什么、能享受什么的各种态度、偏见和假设时，我们还没有实现完全的包容。总的来说，我们确实让人们更容易进入建筑物了。但我们是否完成了让人们更容易接受教育的工作？为了不仅能拥有一份工作，还能拥有一个职业，这些东西对许多人来说还不存在。即使在伯克利也是如此。
But here's what hits you when you go into Lawrence's office. It's in a building called the Ed Roberts Campus. But here's what hits you when you go into Lawrence's office. It's in a building called the Ed Roberts campus, and there are actually about a dozen other disability rights organizations in that building too. The place sprawls over an entire block in Berkeley. And every single thing about it is designed for everybody to use. Inside, like a great celebratory piece of art, is this huge, orange, spiraling ramp. It's two stories high. It's one of the ways to move between the first and second
但当你走进劳伦斯的办公室时，你会有一种触动。它位于一栋名为“埃德·罗伯茨园区”的建筑里。但当你走进劳伦斯的办公室时，你会有一种触动。它位于一栋名为“埃德·罗伯茨园区”的建筑里，大楼里实际上还有大约十几家残疾人权利组织。这个地方横跨了伯克利的一整个街区。关于它的每一件事都是为所有人使用而设计的。在内部，像一件伟大的庆祝艺术品一样，是一个巨大的、橙色的螺旋坡道。它有两层楼高。这是在第一层和第二层之间移动的方式之一。
floors and all around the ramp, the curved walls are lined with giant photos of demonstrations over the years. So if you're listening to this wall walking, and you happen to reach an intersection that's got a curb cut, maybe a bumpy one that lets blind people feel by cane where the sidewalk ends and the street begins. You might hold up for just a second. The most important thing I think people can realize is that by noting it, stopping, pausing, paying attention the next time you walk down the street, the next time you try to cross the street. Say a little thank you if you will.
在坡道周围，弯曲的墙壁上挂满了多年来示威活动的巨幅照片。所以，如果你在听这段录音时正在走路，恰好走到一个有路缘坡道的地方，也许是一个凹凸不平的坡道，让盲人可以用手杖感觉到人行道在哪里结束，街道在哪里开始。你可能会停顿一下。我认为人们能意识到的最重要的事情是，通过注意到它，停下来，暂停，在下次走在街上时，在下次尝试过马路时多加留意。如果可以的话，说声小小的谢谢。
Curb cuts haven't just been helpful for wheelchair riders, but also for people pushing strollers and shopping carts for elderly people who use walkers for bicyclists. And this phenomenon has come to be known as the curb cut effect. Roman Mars will be back to talk with reporter Cynthia Gourney about it right after this. So let's just start with the idea. What is the curb cut effect? The term gets used to describe a fix that is made to help a particular disadvantaged group of people. In this case, for example, putting ramps into sidewalk curbs so that people who roll because they have to can get across a street safely at an intersection.
路缘坡道不仅对轮椅使用者有帮助，对推婴儿车和购物推车的人、使用助行器的老年人以及骑自行车的人也很有帮助。这种现象被称为“路缘坡道效应”。罗曼·马斯稍后会回来与记者辛西娅·古尔尼讨论这个问题。那么，让我们从这个概念开始。什么是路缘坡道效应？这个术语被用来描述为帮助特定的弱势群体而做出的改进。在这种情况下，例如，在人行道路缘上设置坡道，以便那些因为必须坐轮椅而滚动的人能够安全地穿过路口。
But it's got much wider applications because it turns out that there are a lot of these fixes you do that end up having helpful ramifications for a huge group of people. The GI Bill, for example, after World War II, designed specifically to help veterans end up helping an enormous, wide-ranging population in the United States, the home building industry, you know, entire suburban communities, etc. And so who's the first person to apply the curb cut metaphor to this idea? Nobody knows who came up with the term the curb cut effect, at least let me rephrase that. I don't know who came up with the term somebody out there surely knows. I was not able to find out. The idea, however, has been around for quite some time.
但它有更广泛的应用，因为事实证明，你所做的许多这类改进最终会对一大群人产生有益的影响。例如，二战后的《退伍军人权利法案》，专门为帮助退伍军人而设计，最终帮助了美国一个庞大而广泛的人群，包括房屋建筑业、整个郊区社区等等。那么，谁是第一个将路缘坡道隐喻应用到这个想法上的人呢？没人知道是谁想出了“路缘坡道效应”这个词，至少让我换个说法。我不知道是谁想出了这个词，肯定有人知道。我没能查出来。然而，这个想法已经存在很长一段时间了。
out. The idea, however, has been around for quite some time. And the most interesting example of recent times that I learned about came from Steve Brown, the disability historian we heard from earlier. Steve told me that at one point recently while he was doing a radio program about his work and disability history, he got a phone call from his own parents who said, well, Steve, that was all very interesting. You were good on the show, but don't you remember that back in Kalamazoo Michigan where you grew up, by the way, we had some curb cuts and Steve said, what? And it turned out that in the 1940s in Kalamazoo, a disabled or injured veteran had gotten so fed up watching other disabled vets struggling up and down the curbs in Kalamazoo. Kalamazoo turns out, apparently at least at that time, to have extremely high, unusually high curbs because of river flooding. And this guy talked the city officials into just in a very few corners downtown cutting
出来。然而，这个想法已经存在很长一段时间了。我了解到的最近最有趣的例子来自史蒂夫·布朗，就是我们之前听到的那位残疾史学家。史蒂夫告诉我，最近有一次他在做一个关于他的工作和残疾史的广播节目时，接到了他父母的电话，他们说，嗯，史蒂夫，这很有趣。你在节目里表现得很好，但你不记得在你长大的密歇根州卡拉马祖，顺便说一句，我们有一些路缘坡道吗？史蒂夫说，什么？结果发现，在20世纪40年代的卡拉马祖，一位残疾或受伤的退伍军人看到其他残疾退伍军人在卡拉马祖的路缘上挣扎，感到非常厌烦。卡拉马祖当时因为河流洪水，路缘非常高，异常高。这个人说服了城市官员在市中心的极少数角落切开
ramps into the curbs. They did it. People started using it and they got so interested in what was happening that they decided to study it somewhat formally and see what effect it was having. And so Steve told me the officials commissioned a report. So it said that the curb ramps not only helped people and wheelchairs and people who use the crutches but women and did say women, pushing strollers and delivery men with their deliveries and bicyclists, and then it kind of ended with something like it was
路缘坡道。他们做到了。人们开始使用它，他们对发生的事情非常感兴趣，以至于决定正式研究它，看看它产生了什么影响。所以史蒂夫告诉我，官员们委托了一份报告。报告说，路缘坡道不仅帮助了坐轮椅的人和使用拐杖的人，还帮助了推婴儿车的妇女——确实说了妇女——以及送货员和骑自行车的人，然后它以类似“它正在为每个人创造行动自由”的话结束。
creating freedom of movement for everybody. And it turns out there are lots of examples of this that were devised for people who had certain disadvantages, but really benefit all of us. Okay, you're in a really noisy bar. You're watching the basketball game. You're following it with the captions. You're experiencing the curb cut effect. You're trying to get into a building.
事实证明，有很多这样的例子，它们最初是为那些有特定劣势的人设计的，但实际上造福了我们所有人。好吧，你在一个非常嘈杂的酒吧里。你在看篮球比赛。你跟着字幕看。你正在体验路缘坡道效应。你正试图进入一栋大楼。
Your hands are full of packages. You use the special electronic button or the button that you can just hit with your hip. You've just used a thing that was made for somebody who can't push a door or in the earlier example, somebody who can't hear. We run into examples like this all the time without being aware of it. And in fact, when I started working on this story, whenever I would say to people, curb cuts, they would generally, especially if they were under the age of about 60 and had not been around Berkeley
你的手里拿满了包裹。你使用了特殊的电子按钮，或者你可以用臀部按下的按钮。你刚刚使用了一个为那些无法推门的人，或者在之前的例子中，为那些听不见的人制造的东西。我们一直都在遇到这样的例子，却没有意识到。事实上，当我开始做这个故事时，每当我向人们提到“路缘坡道”时，他们通常会说——特别是如果他们不到60岁，而且没有在伯克利生活过
when the stuff I'm talking about was happening, they would say, oh, you mean those things that are in the sidewalk so you can put your rollie bag or your stroller more easily so you can get those off the curb? Right. They thought it was meant for them. That's correct.
当我谈论的事情发生时——他们会说，哦，你是说人行道上的那些东西，这样你就可以更容易地放你的行李箱或婴儿车，这样你就可以把它们从路缘上弄下来？对。他们以为那是为他们准备的。没错。
And not for people who are surveyed in the wheelchair. What was the strang them, and not for people in the survey. That's correct. What was the strangest, most unexpected curb cut effect that you found in your research? So the football huddle turns out to have been invented at Gallaudet University, the National University of the Deaf for students who couldn't hear. Because Gallaudet in the late 1800s, early 1900s, we had a football team and they had to figure out a way to communicate with each other so they got in a huddle and we're signing to each other and therefore we can't the huddle.
而不是为坐轮椅的人准备的。在你的研究中，你发现的最奇怪、最意想不到的路缘坡道效应是什么？事实证明，橄榄球的“列阵商议”（huddle）是由加劳德特大学发明的，这是为听不见的学生设立的国立聋人大学。因为在19世纪末、20世纪初，加劳德特有一支橄榄球队，他们必须想出一种相互交流的方法，所以他们聚在一起商议，并用手语交流，因此我们有了“列阵商议”。
So it's weird to be that's a true. It's true. Look it up. So I looked it up. It is true. They were signing because they were playing other deaf teams and they got into a huddle because they didn't want the other deaf teams to be able to read their signs. So now of course every team in the NFL uses the football huddle.
所以这很奇怪，这是真的。是真的。去查查吧。所以我查了一下。这是真的。他们当时在用手语，因为他们在和其他聋人球队比赛，他们聚在一起商议是因为他们不想让其他聋人球队读懂他们的手语。所以现在当然，NFL的每一支球队都在使用橄榄球的“列阵商议”。
That makes so much sense. I wouldn't have thought of that because across a field you could talk openly if you had hearing teams and they couldn't hear you. Exactly. You would never be fine. That's amazing. So this is connected to a bigger idea that I think a lot of designers and maybe a lot of other people now called universal design.
这太有道理了。我没想到这一点，因为如果你有听力正常的球队，他们听不见你说话，你可以在球场上公开交谈。没错。你永远不会被发现。这太神奇了。所以这与一个更大的想法有关，我想很多设计师，也许现在很多其他人称之为“通用设计”。
So how is this all connected? Well, the person who is generally cited as the father of universal design, although it's not clear that he actually invented that term. He's deceased now was an architect named Ron Mace out of North Carolina. He himself was a wheelchair user. And he did a lot of very influential writing. The general message being, look, we shouldn't be thinking about just people in wheelchairs or just people who can't see or hear when we design. We should be thinking about
那么这一切是如何联系在一起的呢？嗯，通常被认为是“通用设计之父”的人——尽管不清楚他是否真的发明了这个词——现在已经去世了，他是一位来自北卡罗来纳州的建筑师，名叫罗恩·梅斯。他本人就是一名轮椅使用者。他写了很多非常有影响力的文章。总的信息是，看，我们在设计时，不应该只考虑坐轮椅的人，或者只考虑看不见或听不见的人。我们应该考虑
designs that work for everybody, regardless of their mobility, their ability to see, their ability to hear, their age, and there's among architects who are advocates of universal design, there's a set of seven principles, which are too elaborate to enumerate here, but they're very straightforward. They're like things should be simple. They should be easy to use. They should be widely accessible. They should use the best available materials. And so the curb cut has turned out
适合所有人的设计，无论他们的行动能力、视觉能力、听觉能力、年龄如何。在倡导通用设计的建筑师中，有一套七项原则，这里太复杂无法一一列举，但它们非常直观。它们就像是事物应该简单。它们应该易于使用。它们应该广泛可及。它们应该使用最好的可用材料。所以路缘坡道已经成为
to be a classic example of universal design because anybody who rolls uses it. Right. Mostly, I think that people think of universal design in the physical space with like nice script handles for people who maybe are arthritic and curb cuts and things. But the next frontier of universal design is in the virtual space, because the internet is the place
通用设计的经典例子，因为任何滚动的人都会使用它。没错。我想人们大多认为通用设计是在物理空间中，比如为可能患有关节炎的人设计的漂亮把手，以及路缘坡道等等。但通用设计的下一个前沿是在虚拟空间，因为互联网是我们所有人生活得越来越多、花费时间越来越多的地方。通用设计是如何应用于虚拟世界的？是的，除了橄榄球的“列阵商议”是为聋人开始的之外，我在所有这些报道中第二喜欢的短语是“电子路缘坡道”。哇。这是信息技术领域的人们现在使用的术语
where all of us are living more and more of our lives, more of our time. How is universal design being applied to the virtual worlds? Yeah, aside from the football huddle start being started for the deaf, my second favorite phrase in all of this reporting was, Electronic Curb Cuts. Wow. Which is the term that people who work in information technology are now using
来谈论如何使技术变得可及，让那些看不见、听不见、在过去无法使用鼠标、无法在键盘上打字的人能够使用。黛比·卡普兰，我们在节目早些时候见到的那位最初参与“独立生活中心”的人，就是做这个的。这现在是她的专长。
to talk about ways to make that technology accessible, available to people who can't see, can't hear, can't use a mouse in the old days, can't type on a keyboard. And Debbie Kaplan, the person who had originally been involved in the Center for Independent Living that we met earlier in the program, does this. This is her specialty now.
她致力于技术的可及性，信息技术，即电子路缘坡道。你知道，我们这些为建筑环境的可及性而奋斗的人，当我们意识到电子环境正在被构建，并越来越多地成为日常生活的一部分时，我们意识到我们需要迅速参与进来。他们是如何参与进来的？我认为他们想要解决的最早的一些问题是，你如何让计算机信息对那些看不见、听不见、不能使用键盘的人可用？所以他们产生的大部分工作最终成为了我们日常生活中的一个因素。Siri和Alexa能够识别你的声音，是因为最初为那些需要以这种方式操作计算机的人设计的技术。有一个程序——记录在案，我永远不会使用——允许你的电子邮件在你开车时读给你听，对吧？这再次来自于
She works on accessibility of technology, information technology, i.e. electronic curb cuts. You know, those of us who fought for accessibility of the built environment when we realized that the electronic environment was getting built all around and becoming more and more a part of daily life, we realized that we needed to get involved quickly. And how did they get involved? I think that some of the earliest problems that they wanted to address were, how do you make computer information available to people who cannot see, who cannot
由致力于电子路缘坡道的人们开发的那种技术。最初被认为是仅供轮椅使用者使用的东西，最终被所有人视为理所当然，并以最初未曾预料到的方式使用，造福了比最初设想的更多的人。这对我们为使电子环境可及而做的事情也是如此。现在，通用设计和路缘坡道效应已经成为关于设计应该如何做好的一个被广泛持有、没有争议的观点，那么我们在建筑世界或电子世界的设计状态处于什么位置呢？嗯，我会通过描述我与黛比·卡普兰在一起的一点时间，来总结我在学习这个过程中的个人经历。
hear, who can't use a keyboard? So a lot of the work that they produced ends up being a factor in our daily lives. Siri and Alexa can recognize your voice because of technology that was originally designed for people who need to be able to address a computer in that way. There is a program that let the record show, I will never use, that allows your email to be read back to you while you're driving your car, right? That again comes from the kind of technology
在我们见面的时候，黛比住在华盛顿特区外。与黛比·卡普兰共度一小时就像是上了一门关于残疾人改进措施的进展和持续挑战的速成课，至少在美国是这样。在这方面，我们比大多数社会更先进。黛比是一名律师。她实际上是一位老朋友。我和我丈夫认识她很多年了。
that was developed by people working on electronic curb cuts. What was originally thought of as something just for people in wheelchairs ended up being just taken for granted by everybody and used in ways that weren't even originally anticipated for the benefit of many, many more people than originally thought of. That's true for the things that we do to make the electronic environment accessible also. Now that universal design and the curb-cut effect is a pretty widely held, uncontroversial opinion of how design should be done well, where are we in the state of design in the built world or the electronic world? Well, I would sort of sum that up in my own experience of learning about this by describing a little bit about my time with Debbie Kaplan.
她有一份非常有趣的工作，致力于电子路缘坡道和信息设计。她住在一个按照通用设计原则设计的社区，对所有人都是无障碍的。她有一辆方便的电动轮椅，可以带她去任何她需要去的地方。我们在冬天去了那里。所以你和黛比一起坐电梯下去，然后走到街上。这很艰难。银泉市有路缘坡道，但人行道上有雪。有人
At the time that we were meeting with each other, Debbie lived just outside Washington, DC. And spending an hour with Debbie Kaplan is like a crash course in the advances and ongoing challenges of disability fixes, at least in the United States. We are more advanced than most societies in this regard. Debbie is an attorney. She's actually an old friend. My husband and I have known her for many years.
把自行车留在人行道上，现在我们在湾区这里。有人把这些新滑板车到处乱放。每次我现在看到滑板车，我就会想到坐轮椅的人，对吧？当时有雪，有雪，我转头对黛比说，他们有没有额外努力去清理积雪，为了那些坐轮椅的人，他们不能像步行的人那样四处走动？她看着我，突然大笑起来，说，你在开玩笑吗？
She has a very interesting job working on electronic curb cuts and information design. She lives in a community that has been designed with universal design principles, accessible to everybody. She has a handy power wheelchair that gets her everywhere she needs to go. We were there in the winter. So you go down and then I successful elevator with Debbie and you go out in the street. And it's tough. There are curb cuts in Silver Spring but there's also snow on the sidewalk. There's people
所以我们已经走了很长一段路。我想任何目前正在或即将与残疾作斗争的人都会明白我们还有多长的路要走。是的，这不仅仅是关于制造事物时的通用设计原则。我们必须将其融入到我们的行为和我们彼此之间的礼貌感中。正是如此。是的，正是如此。非常感谢。谢谢。99% Invisible本周由辛西娅·古尔尼制作，由我们的执行制片人德莱尼·霍尔在2018年编辑并担任客座主持。混音制作由Serefusif完成，音乐由肖恩·里豪创作。
who left their bicycles on the sidewalk now here where we are in the Bay Area. There's people leaving these new scooters all over the place. Every time I see a scooter now I think of people in wheelchairs, right? There was snow was snow, and I said, I turned to Debbie at one point and said, well, did they make an extra effort to come and clear the snow for people who are in wheelchairs who can't just dart around at the way somebody on foot can? And she looked at me and just burst out laughing and said, are you joking?
库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊、莫什·马登、薇薇安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、凯蒂·明格尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·佩鲁比、索菲亚·克洛茨格，还有我，罗曼·马斯。我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区。在美丽的。
So we've come a very long way. And I think anybody who is presently or about to be grappling with disability will understand how long away we still have to go. Yeah, and it's not just about universal design principles in the making of things. We have to incorporate that in just our behavior and our sense of courtesy towards one another. Precisely. Yeah, precisely. Thank you so much. Thank you. 99% invisible was produced this week by Cynthia Gourney, edited and guest hosted by our executive producer Delaney Hall back in 2018. Mix Intek Production was by Serefusif, music by Sean Rihau.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰的上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马斯，或者@节目99PI.org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以在我们的网站99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他来自Stitcher的节目，包括丹·帕什曼的《The Sporkful》。我认识丹很多年了，他是第一个在公司Slack上跟我打招呼的人。所以，你应该听听《The Sporkful》。如果你想听任何旧的99PI剧集或阅读任何文章，它们都还在那里。在99PI.org。
Kurt Colstad is the digital director of the rest of the team, includes Christopher Johnson, Mosh Madon, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mingle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Perubey, Sophia Klotzger, and me Roman Mars. We are now a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north. In beautiful.
新公司还没有给我那个官方音频标志，所以。巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达-巴达- sex and um 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 9-9-PI org or on Instagram and read it too. You can find other shows I love from Stitcher on our website, Nine-Night PI.org, including the Sportful from Dan Pashman. I've known Dan for years and years, and he was the first person to say hi to me on the
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。您可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在Twitter上关注Roman Mars或本节目，地址是99pi.org，也可以在Instagram上关注并阅读相关内容。您可以在我们的网站99pi.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目，包括Dan Pashman的《The Sporkful》。我和Dan认识很多年了，他是第一个在公司Slack上跟我打招呼的人。
company Slack. So, you should listen to the Sportful. If you want to listen to any of the older Nine-Night PI episodes or read any of the articles, they're all still there. At Nine-Night PI dot org. of the older 99-Vi episodes or read any of the articles, they're all still there at 99-PI.org. The new company didn't get me one of those official audio logos yet, so. Bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada- sex and um There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，您应该听听《The Sporkful》。如果您想收听任何往期的99pi节目或阅读文章，它们都还在99pi.org上。新公司还没给我弄到那些官方音频标志，所以……巴达巴达……（此处省略重复音效）……目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。